foreign
as you know there have been lots of
layoffs even from the biggest tech
companies meta laid off more than 11 000
employees Amazon cut about 18 000 jobs
and Google just cut six percent which is
12 000 employees and that includes the
31 massage therapists that got let go
the Google employees who managed to
avoid Mass layoffs may have to continue
doing their jobs without on-site
massages
my condolences not only is it shocking
to see Google lay off 12 000 employees
but the way they did it was also
shocking let's watch this clip from a
Google employee a day in my life getting
laid off at Google so I woke up to this
really ominous text from my boss and I
honestly had no idea what it was going
to be about so I called her the minute I
woke up and saw this and she told me to
check the news and my email so I rushed
downstairs to find out that I had lost
access to basically everything I
couldn't log into my email or even check
my calendar I called my boss back and we
just sobbed over the phone because she
was also finding out about my layoff for
the first time today too I started
getting calls from a bunch of my
co-workers and started finding out who
else was let go on my team and some
neighboring teams as well but I think
the worst part is that it seems like no
one was consulted on this decision and
everyone was just finding out about the
layoffs at the same time it just felt
like a really bad game of Russian
Roulette and there was no consistency
around who was let go it was also not
Performance Based so it just felt really
random it seemed like there was no heads
up at all no conversation with your
manager and the layoffs felt pretty
random as it wasn't even based on your
performance and then one day your access
to everything just gets cut off
immediately without communication
just like the way my ex broke up with me
I think a lot of these companies simply
over hired and overspent during the
pandemic and are now finally addressing
it
generally you want to avoid doing
layoffs because it looks so bad for your
company
everyone else is doing it now it became
kind of like socially acceptable to do
so so every company jumps at the chance
to fire people without the blame for
handling things poorly here's an analogy
if you're in a classy restaurant and
you're holding the biggest fart of your
life you're going to want to keep that
fart in even if it kills you because you
don't want to be known as the guy who
farts at fancy restaurants but if
suddenly everyone around you is ripping
out massive farts then you don't feel so
bad letting one out yourself anymore
basically if you fart alone you're a
villain but if you fart in solidarity
with the people now you're selling a
victim and farting is an act of protest
and together you could turn the blame on
the food or the restaurant or on
macroeconomic conditions
was there anything that these Tech
Giants could have done differently to
prevent these massive layoffs was there
another solution
to even start answering these questions
I think the first thing we have to ask
is why these layoffs even happen
I think it all comes down to leverage
and tech companies were over leveraged
Leverage is a tool it helps you get more
out of what you have leverage comes in
many forms the simplest form of Leverage
would be to take out a loan to invest in
stocks Tech startups also take on a form
of Leverage startups will raise money
spend money to hire more people
subsidize your services operate at a
loss they're willing to lose money in
the beginning for the sake of growing
quickly and capturing the market even
before they figure out their unit
economics
if the startup gets to a stable place
and is profitable then it's all good so
in this case taking on Leverage was
totally worth it investors are happy
since they made their money back faster
but what happens when you never get the
profitability and your business model
simply doesn't work
then you get a startup like bird the
electric scooter sharing company that
spawned dozens of copycats at the peak
of 2019 the streets were littered with
scooters for a couple of dollars you
could ride them for 15 minutes it was an
awesome way to get around the city if
you don't mind looking like a Suburban
Mall Cop
but was it sustainable was bird
profitable per ride no in fact it was
also extremely dangerous which caused
issues for the company let's look at a
clip
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can see why electric scooter
companies get a bad rep
this guy clearly didn't park his scooter
back in its designated area he just left
it there in the middle of the street
without the cooperation of the customers
it simply won't work
also I've never seen anyone walk away so
casually after getting hit by a car
before anyway buying scooters and
renting them out was not a sustainable
business but VC money was flowing in and
scooter companies expanded across the
country and even internationally at the
peak bird was worth 2.3 billion dollars
when it went public through a spec and
now it's only worth 70 million which
means if you invested a hundred dollars
when it iPod your shares would be now
worth three dollars how did a
non-profitable company get so overvalued
why did people even buy into that it's
because in 2020 the market was filled
with greed and spax were a vessel to
carry through that greed specs were hot
[__] everyone wanted to invest in them
normally when a company goes public
through an IPO it must go through a
highly regulated process that often
takes over a year armies of investment
bankers and lawyers comb through the
details of your company to make sure
they meet the sec's requirements it's an
expensive process in terms of money time
and just pure hassle internally all that
just so that you could penetrate through
that SEC tunnel and IPO
but a spec can facilitate that process a
spec is a company with the bare minimum
a board a management team a bank account
that company Zips through the IPO
process and since there's literally
nothing it's a shell company it's fast
and cheap afterwards it raises money
from people looking to get rich quick to
acquire a private company like bird so
they can go public spax allowed
companies to go public without the
scrutiny of a real IPO it was the
perfect instrument for Wall Street
insiders to get rich by selling off
their shares to us at an inflated price
because of the hype and then the rest
was history
2020 was the year of SPAC 250 billion
dollars were poured into them the story
might sound familiar because the same
thing happened with crypto in retrospect
everybody was scrambling for get rich
quick schemes Venture Capital funds had
so much money to throw around the moment
your startup pitch had the word web3
created economy or blockchain they jizz
in their pants and they beg you to take
their money it was the zero interest
rate phenomenon meaning interest rates
were so low that borrowing money was
basically free which flooded the market
with all this extra cash and everything
went up
but the music was going to stop at some
point at that time Ray dalio a
billionaire hedge fund manager said cash
is trash because during a bull market
almost anything you invest in will go up
because everyone else is also investing
in it so holding cash is literally the
worst thing you can do for your
Financial Health
well actually the worst thing would be
to spend it on a banana duct tape to a
wall for 120 000 like it's going to turn
to compost what were you thinking anyway
the overall sentiment then was if you're
holding cash you're a [__] loser
I don't want to be a loser I don't want
to fall behind I see my friends getting
rich on Meme stocks crypto nfts it
doesn't matter as long as they'll make
me money I'll drain my savings account
if I need to even the most conservative
investors once we're in a bull market
you can convince them to invest in a
cartoon picture of a rock
that jpeg sold for 1.3 million dollars
that's more than this photograph of a
potato which only sold for a million
dollars at least this one is a real
tangible photo
and this potato looks pretty [__]
sick basically people rather be poor
together than feel left behind by
everyone else getting rich and that's
the zero interest rate epidemic
now big tech companies are not immune to
this epidemic they develop fomo too the
fear of missing out every tech company
and their moms are spending money to
expand and scale their businesses you
have no choice but to keep up and also
spend that cash you don't want to be
left behind remember cash is trash so
what did Google do they spent and hired
aggressively even if they didn't have a
solid plan on how to deploy that Capital
effectively or how to make use of the
talent they hired that's why you see
overqualification low impact work
bloated teams and a bunch of employees
making Day in the Life tick tocks stay
in the life as a 23 year old product
manager at meta I always journal in the
morning I then do a quick workout
routine I get dressed I try to look cute
every day got some food at the office I
make a coffee every single morning I
need that I did some work on the roof
worked until lunch and then ate up there
here's me being cute I got a snack
always I then shuttled home The View so
pretty met up with some friends for
dinner and then my boyfriend came over
and was acting like a DJ for my dog
that used to be me man now I have to
actually make YouTube videos now things
are starting to unwind Ray dalio no
longer thinks cash is trash interest
rates are actually coming back to a
reasonable level so these tech companies
have to undo what they did since their
revenue couldn't keep up with the pace
of their spending though it was their
mismanagement of their leverage the
employees are the ones who had to pay
the price
all right that's it for today if you
like these videos let me know if you
don't
say that you like them anyways because
it makes me feel good about myself
okay I'll see you in the next video